dan wakey oh look who's back l.a times
he covers the nba also covers the
clippers and you got a smile on your
face but you might be the only person
involved with the clippers
with a smile on your face if i told you
two weeks ago we'd be having this
conversation today dan what would you
have said
i said i've seen this movie before dan
is what i would say that i was there in
in 2015 um when they were up 3-1 against
the rockets and i've seen this team
be faced well this organization uh be
faced with success
and kind of run in the opposite
direction for whatever reason whether
something
out of their control has happened or you
know in this case seemingly
the the pressure just got to them and um
to see what happened three games in a
row to see this team below
47 points worth of leads and elimination
games
um is just stunning it it truly is and
then
on top of it to watch sort of the um
seemingly the collective of the nba
dance on their graves in the aftermath
in itself is is almost another
indictment so
it's been a it's been a rough night for
the clippers that's for sure i mentioned
this in the first hour and you'd know
better than i would but it felt like
these clippers almost
felt like they had won titles you know
kawhi had won a title and doc had won a
title it felt like the other guys
acted like they had won a title before
that we somehow
are on the easy path at disney world to
get to the conference finals
and then all of a sudden i thought that
they were in trouble against dallas
i thought dallas had the potential to
upset them in the first round
nobody was heeding any of that advice or
warning and then all of a sudden you see
these next two series here
we love to point the finger here where
do you point the finger first here on
blame
well i to me it starts with the stars um
that that's who this stuff falls on in
the playoffs and kawhi leonard and paul
george were nowhere near good enough
last night
um i think you know kawhi leonard looked
really tentative late in the game
paul george is wide open from the corner
and
shoots a three off the side of the
backboard a
pretty pretty stunning moment and and
then i think you know you you talk to
these guys after the game and you hear
paul george talking about process and
talking about how
you know um it wasn't championship or
bust in his mind internally that that's
that they knew that and and look if i'm
in the clippers front office
and and i obviously only one team can
win right
but but it certainly was conference
finals or plus uh you know or
nba finals or buzz like there is a 12
year old
in america probably doing saying god
knows what about the clippers on twitter
that the oklahoma city thunder will be
able to draft with the clippers draft
pick
in six years right like that's how far
down the line
the clippers have mortgaged their future
for this moment and a lot of stuff has
happened between when that trade was
made and and obviously last night
um there are excuses to be made all over
the place
but i i think ultimately again
they had double-digit leads and three
straight elimination games and they
weren't able to close the door and each
time dan they it was weird being in that
building um
shooters talk about this stuff all the
time where they talk
sorry about that um
sorry is that political it is not oh
it's not poultry
it is not sadly it is not paul george um
i apologize
the uh i wish it was paul what would you
say to paul george if that was him
i mean i would honestly i would i'd ask
if he really believed what he said
last night you know and because i think
it's i don't i don't think he can
right like that that can't be really how
he truly feels about this team
and and i think you know hopefully i
would try to goad out of him that
you know are you just searching for
answers in this moment is that what this
is about
are you just looking for um are you just
looking for
for a reason to explain the
unexplainable and for it to not just be
we're the clippers and like we're gonna
have to work twice as hard to overcome
this stuff just because of sort of the
emotional baggage
that comes with being a part of this
franchise i just wonder about the bright
lights here
because kawhi has been in the bright
lights nobody else has been in the
bright lines this is in oklahoma city
this is in indiana for paul george
and it's not just on him there are other
guys that
you know it got bright and it got hot
and
they sort of fell apart here and i don't
want to lose sight of what denver
accomplished here because completely we
knew they were going to be
spent in game one and i just didn't know
how they would rally and down
3-1 it almost felt like that's a let's
just
check out of the bubble and let's just
go home but
they had more depth than the clippers
did and their star players in the last
three games
acted like stars unlike we saw with the
clippers
well let's do this real quick and i i
think i think you're on to something
here dan
paul george last night one of the things
another one of the things he said that i
thought was really illuminating was that
he's never been a favorite before
but this is somebody who's always been
an underdog throughout his career he's
played for underdog
franchises he went to fresno state right
like that
essentially admitting that it took some
use to it took some time and maybe he
wasn't quite used to having everybody
sort of gunned for him
right and for him to be a part of that
team um but you do you're
right you look up and down this roster
and you say i mean what has patrick
beverly ever won in the nba he hasn't
won anything he hasn't played that like
the super high level of games has lou
williams or mantras harold ever been in
this situation they have not
and they absolutely look like players
that had not been in this situation you
have blue williams one of the great
scores of
off the bench in the league history
blowing the layup after layup after
layup
you know it was it was at a certain
point it's almost cringing you cringe
you watch the stuff and you see
these guys and they they have no idea
what is happening to them
um and you know so i do think that
you're right that this
you know the championship experience on
this roster i think was overstated
um certainly it's easy to say that
through the hindsight of 2020 and
i just i feel like they've got a lot of
really big decisions to make this summer
or well i'm sorry this off season force
i have it um
and you know his dog safe
it's a good question you know it's hard
it would be hard to say so definitively
i think um it's something
his voice within that organization dan
is so valued
um he has carried them through some
incredibly rocky waters
and he has earned a lot of trust and a
lot of credibility
um from steve ballmer on down in in that
organization i mean this is somebody who
um was essentially functionally demoted
from a front from a front office
position
only to do then his best coaching jobs
um
you know with lesser talent this year
though obviously i mean he said it after
the game like
if it should be on somebody it should be
on me um i think he partly believes that
i think he also is partly just trying to
protect his players
he's dan wakey he covers the nba and the
clippers for the la times
if you're the lakers how do you think
lebron is reacting to this
i mean i don't think we have to wonder i
mean they were they were part of the the
dunk parade on twitter last night too
not necessarily
lebron but you know jared dudley is
tweeting
crying face emojis and stuff like this
and i mean again i think it speaks to
sort of your point that
maybe the clippers acted like a team
that
you know had more on the trophy case
than actually there
um he shouldn't be too excited though
um because denver i mean if
what more evidence do we need that
denver is a dangerous team than what
we've seen in their last six elimination
games
um than what we've seen from michael
malone that what we've seen from nicole
yokic like this beautiful
glacier-moving player
you know who's just slow and devastating
and it's like throwing water polo passes
it's
i mean like this is this guy is like
incredible you have jamal
murray who is playing as confidently as
anybody in the nba
and like yeah and you mentioned some
really good functional depth
yeah and um it's it like to me like they
shouldn't feel like
that uh you know to borrow one of your
disney like the fast pass to the to the
finals is there um
it's not denver woke up a fight i i just
think that
um and i think people around the league
always felt that the team best equipped
to beat
the lakers was the clippers and on top
of the drama that we all wanted from the
la
versus la series uh you know that it was
also
probably the best chance to just to
knock lebron james
off and at this point i mean it just
seems like it seems like they're gonna
have a pretty big advantage in the
finals and it feels like
the other series is the consolation
series with the heat against the celtics
but
i've said to my audience the last
when they we started the milwaukee
series i said the heat the heat can beat
the bucks
make no mistake about it um and they're
they're gaining that confidence there i
don't know if they win this series
but if you're looking at a formidable
opponent
in the uh finals uh who do you think is
more formidable the celtics or the heat
i mean boston i think matches up better
talent-wise but but i do think there's
something super special about what's
happening in miami
or with miami um before the start of
that buck series i asked mike
buttonholzer
if he saw any parallels between this
heat team and last year's raptors team
and and he did and i mean in terms of
tough-minded together
um you know a star that can lift you up
on both ends of the floor
um you know jimmy butler sort of in that
kawhi leonard role
and and i do think i i just i wrote a
story about duncan robinson
um earlier this week and it you know
it's funny you talk to these guys on
this team you have duncan robinson a guy
who before he's at michigan
has to go play the division three school
you have jimmy butler who played at a
community college you have
jay crowder who played at a community
college you have these guys that are
used to playing in these empty buildings
doing whatever it takes to to win and
it's funny you just feel like they're
sort of built for this
dan it really does feel like that the
heat's fabric and their culture is
almost exist
specifically to be let's put you in this
you know on
this crazy position where you're not
going to be able to see your family
you know it's going to be all focused on
basketball and you're going to have to
buy 100 in
miami more than any other team seems
like to be embracing that
truly good to visit with you dan and uh
are how does this affect your mood that
the clippers are out there like you
you cover them primarily but how does it
affect you
of now you're covering who
well i mean lee i'll be at lakers i'll
be you know doing obviously some lakers
stuff a lot of lake
your stuff and then i'll be there uh you
know i think like everybody i mean i
wanted to see that series
and and that to me is part of the story
that
and like the unfortunate part sort of
about the clipper story in general is
that
you know the parallels to that 2015 team
and the situations up 3-1 with if you
remember that was they were going to
play the golden state warriors and those
two teams hated each other
and it was the one series that everybody
wanted to see and the clippers didn't
show up
for that party right and it's just like
you you feel like you you know you're
walking into the movie to see the
godfather and you end up
with like mickey blue eyes or something
instead nice
nice timely references i know yeah
thank you dan great to talk to you all
right be good dan that's dan wiki
he covers the nba the clippers for the
la times